[Musique]
il
nous sommes aujourd'hui à marcq un
village tout près d'eux touahri pour
vous proposer un véritable voyage dans
le temps au sein du garage était vintage
classic car nous allons découvrir des
véhicules datant des années 30 jusqu aux
années 90 suivez-moi
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et pour commencer ce voyage dans le
temps nous sommes avec le fondateur et
gérant de ce garage nicolas michaud
bonjour bonjour alors on parcourt
vraiment le xxème siècle de l'histoire
de l'automobile ici un oui tout à fait
il ya plein plein de marques différentes
dans le garage qui nous permet de
raconter d'une multitude d'histoires par
constructeurs par exemple on retrouve
quel type de véhicule différentes
époques aussi tout à fait on a des
véhicules qui vont de 1937 jusqu'à les
années 90 donc on appelle ça aujourd'hui
des young timers mais on a aussi des
voitures anciennes et à une grande
majorité des véhicules les années 50 60
vous avez pris le volant de cette
aventure en 2014 pourquoi vous êtes
lancés alors moi je suis un
collectionneur de voitures anciennes
depuis très longtemps je me suis donné
corps et âme dans cette passion parce
que j'adore ça et un jour j'ai eu une
opportunité professionnelle qui m'a
permis de quitter mon activité et j'ai
créé cette société parce que j'avais eu
l'occasion de voyager aux états unis
j'ai vu que y avait possibilité de faire
venir des voitures en europe mais
c'était quand même un sérieux problème
pour beaucoup de gens de connaître
toutes les tous les problèmes
administratifs qu'on pouvait rencontrer
et petit à petit je me suis également
mis en quête de trouver des véhicules en
bon état parce qu'il y avait beaucoup de
gens qui voulaient acheter des voitures
mais c'est vrai que son marché dont on
n'avait pas une proposition comme celle
que nous propose aujourd'hui c'est
vraiment de la clé en main ont fourni
des véhicules en très bon état le client
prend son véhicule par et le rêve
commence
[Musique]
on commence avec une ford mustang alors
voilà on a un produit phare chez nous
chez gt vintage qui et je dirai le plus
gros de nos ventes mais aussi de nos
services en entretien etc c'est la ford
mustang à l'original est sorti cette
voiture bon ford allait très mal à
l'époque il avait une gamme de produits
qui était pas du tout bien adéquate aux
marchés et donc ils ont dit on va sortir
une petite voiture c'est la ford mustang
et le film c'était la clientèle féminine
une secrétaire voilà c'était la voiture
pour la secrétaire et en fin de compte
quand ils ont sorti le modèle à détroit
ça a été un succès terrible ils ont eu
énormément de commandes et ils ont eu un
succès tellement important que ça à
sauver ford et c'est un modèle qu'ils
ont décliné en plusieurs versions et on
pouvait commander sa mustang comme si on
allait acheter une cuisine c'est à dire
on choisisse et les coloris les
équipements l'intérieur le des
équipements également au niveau des
échappements y avait toute une
ribambelle de d'options qui permettait
de commander une mustang sur mesure vous
allez nous parler d'une perle rare voilà
tout à fait là on a une cadillac une
cadillac de 1941 c'est une voiture on
voit les années 40 aux états unis où
l'ass et l'exubérance des autos qui sont
énormes et donc cette voiture c'est une
des dernières qui est sorti puisque elle
date de novembre 41 et donc comme tout
le monde le sait on le 7 décembre 41
pearl harbour et donc les américains
rentrant guerre et à ce moment là les
chaînes de production cadillac sont
arrêtés il reste que le moteur et on met
les chars derrière en production et on
mettra deux moteurs de cadillac les
mêmes que celles ci dans un char et
c'est comme ça que cadillac à contribuer
à l'effort de guerre donc c'est la
dernière en fait l'année de fabrication
cette cadillac et bien merci nicolas
mission va rejoindre suite tennessee du
coup dans l'atelier
[Musique]
on peut d'un côté faire de la mécanique
pure et d'un autre côté faire des
projets clients comme ce véhicule
derrière sur ce véhicule je suis en
train de réparer le différentiel est le
moteur par rapport à des soucis qu'a eue
clients après après avoir fait de la
route et comme il est venu dans nos
ateliers et qu'il a vu une autre voiture
je suis en train de refaire le moteur
dessus et qu'il a été un peu comblé par
le par le véhicule il m'a demandé aussi
de modifier l'aspect physique du
véhicule pour qu'il ressemble habilite
le fameux film avec steve mcqueen
alors nicolas nippon nous vous
retrouvons pour
faire un petit tour aux mustangs
aller
on
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
eh bien nicolas michaud merci beaucoup
se fait un plaisir je rappelle que vous
êtes le gérant de donc du garage j'étais
vintage classic cars que tu as fait et
donc les personnes qui sont intéressées
peuvent venir nous voir voilà on reçoit
ce rendez-vous et puis on est ouvert la
journée les gens peuvent passer voir les
voitures et puis attention il ya
beaucoup de coups de foudre qui se
provoque dans notre garage et puis
dans le temps voilà tout à fait il ya
pas mal de gens qui craquent donc c'est
que à mon avis la recette fonctionne
merci beaucoup vous en prie
[Musique]